NBA on TNT analyst five-time NBA
all-star and one of my favorite people
and guests good to see you again Chris
Weber here in the flesh
oh is now you were saying you're here in
LA because you're heading up the coast
to go you're doing a preseason game on
turn right smart is Marv doing yeah I
thought you had more pool in this you
know like no Chris we have to go arenas
gonna be so beautiful so yeah but I'm
really looking forward to it and you
know the main thing I want to see is how
it translates with fans and one thing I
think that you know you go to a lot of
arenas but maybe the average fan doesn't
get because they give the athletes so
much is that when you change new arenas
a lot of time the feeling in the arena
changes I remember when the palace was
first built and everybody in Detroit it
was like all these car company guys
people not from Detroit suits and it was
like a tea party at the game and it was
terrible it was it was terrible and you
would hear the Pistons talk about the
players talk about he had to bring that
kind of hardhat Detroit City feel back
and I wonder not so much for the Raiders
when they go to Vegas I think that
battle steak has consistent but Oakland
is a beautiful place and a unique city
yes and part of Golden State winning was
the heart you know when Stephen Jackson
and Matt Barnes all them had that we
believe team I wasn't surprised because
they first of all know those are good
guys but they also take on the the
temperament of the city and that's a
cool City and so I hope that it doesn't
get you know sushi eaters and be quiet
and just just talk like yeah at the game
but it does happen you know something no
I know I remember growing up in New York
watching the Knicks in Hubie Brown and
Bernard King was my favorite I loved him
go on the playoffs taking on Isiah and
the Pistons and Kelly Tripucka in the
gel no enjoy you know it was like it was
a total gym yeah where I felt like the
Knicks had no shot to win yeah and then
the Palace of Auburn Hills opened up
yeah so I'm wondering if you're saying
that the the it became a little bit
softer did the Pistons make up for it
themselves by sending Lam beer and
microRNA
we have the palace but bad boys in the
palace I'm sure a couple fights in there
so you're the Lakers are playing in this
game yeah the Lakers are here is never
gonna be pretty good too soon well okay
so now let me get to that before we get
to some other things going on with you
last year you came here and you're like
Lakers aren't a playoff Tim and the
whole world killed me that is correct
except the people that went to Vegas and
I think Charles might have been with you
and in that regard too from because he
was concerned about LeBron getting on
all these flights on the wet from the in
the Western Conference that he didn't
have to do in the Eastern Conference
but you were you were definitely the the
leader of that charge what about this
year what do you think I know it's not
might be a little too early but what do
you think for yes well anytime you got
LeBron I love that you're ahead of the
game and so he and after you Davis I
think it's gonna be I think it's gonna
be something special I still think the
white Howard is probably the most
disrespected player of our generation
and maybe he's earned some of that but
averaging a double-double what he's done
guys are getting 100 million dollar
contracts for that now based on
potential I love their bench I love the
guys they can't have coming off the
bench I still think they need some
deadly knockdown shooter yeah that was
your issue with them last year that they
didn't if you play with LeBron you're
gonna all you got to do is just be ready
to shoot that's why I think that
Westbrook
to change subject go for it he's gonna
have a heck of a career if I was
Westbrook I I'd say I'm not gonna
average any points I'm gonna average 30
assists I'm not gonna shoot it all y'all
been crying about me shooting it you
hate me you hate my best friend Harden
both of y'all gonna hate us now cuz
we're gonna win that's an exciting
storyline for me to follow as well all
year the of course the Lakers the
Clippers and and come on man I think
Houston has something to prove and they
have a chip on the shoulder from
D'Antoni to to harden who I think is
right about the narratives of MVPs and
things and maybe we gift MVPs before the
season starts that I've never been this
excited about a basketball season if if
I didn't play never in my career and so
there's some good things going on in
India right what about c-webb the
the I guess trio that nobody really
talks about cuz we are focused on the
teams that you mentioned you got Utah he
got Denver you got Portland you got
Damian Lillard who knew that when he was
waving bye-bye to Paul George he was
waving bye-bye to the Paul George
Russell Westbrook arrow with that his
way by the OKC's history basically we
waved goodbye to all of that from
half-court pretty ya know those three
which ones do you think are a shot I
think all of them are in I think San
Antonio is in I think we're all sleeping
on San Antonio because they're one of
the best players who's hurt so I think
there are seven teams in the playoffs
right now and everybody else is fighting
for the eighth spot what about the idea
of a sleeper team being the Golden State
Warriors Chris Webber I love I love
seeing stuff in this position because
stuff is a fighter and we forget because
he has the babyface we forget how cold
blooded he is and I love seeing him with
his back against the walkers he's gonna
have some of his best basketball ever
but you know he's gonna you know when
he's proving everybody's wrong he's
talking about me too because you know no
no clay and no splash brothers I don't
see how you I don't see how you could do
it and and one thing I do understand is
that when teams are vulnerable it's
payback time and all those other teams
those younger teams I mean they're gonna
build their season off for getting you
know trying to get that one win on a
cold Tuesday night in January when
they're coming off a back-to-back so
every game is gonna mean so much for
their opponent it's gonna be interesting
to see how how go and stay handles the
other side of the coin and before you
move on what about the East we've hardly
even said a word we haven't said a word
about the East I'm excited to see Kimba
in in in Boston I don't know why because
he's been kind of an underrated player
we think only he can score and things
like that I wonder how it's in I want to
see Brad Stevens step up with his
communication but I heard that embiid
lost 15 pounds if he did that that's
gonna be scary
Philly looks really good and you know
what is Toronto gonna did I heard that
saying that they're gonna defend that
title that's good stuff to say you need
to see it before your Mike Tyson
everybody has a plan okay what about
Atlanta we sleep in on the Hawks what do
you think there's a lot of people
there's a bandwidth
and that seems to be filling up quite a
bit with the whole he's always a
bandwagon for the hogs that's about it
us but we'll leave it there yeah I'd
love Trey I love I love him and I think
he's proved a lot of people wrong I love
the excitement of the arena I love
management shout out to grass Hill but I
think they need a few more players
before you can really get excited about
them Chris whoever here on the Rich
Eisen show let's get to this now I heard
you have an announcement to make
is that a true story yeah yeah well part
of the reason I'm here riches we're
finishing up their guests the the PR run
of the book and putting some things
together and so your autobiography I've
been working on autobiography I think
I've talked or mentioned it a few times
but for the last eight and a half years
and so for me to finally say this done
and you can pre-order it and it'll be
here for Christmas or something is
something pretty cool and I'm proud to
say that that I finished I wrote every
word over the past few years I've been
offered some generous deals by
publications about publishing companies
that type of thing to tell my story and
it was a situation we're finally ready
I've had enough time I've had children
I've been able to retire I've been able
to sit back and just look back and the
name of the book is by God's grace and
I'm just looking back really thankful
that through all everything that I've
been through he sustained me he
sustained my families put wonderful
people around me I was blessed with
children and so it just really is
looking back and saying wow it's it's
been a wonderful ride it's been a tough
ride at times but at the end of the day
God has been there for me and hopefully
it inspires others and and for me really
was therapeutic and now something fun to
give to the people something for my kids
and to continue having fun in the sports
world so people can pre-order it right
now people can pre-order right now
Amazon song anywhere you can buy a book
and is there a date by November November
I'm sorry December 18th it will be in
stores right before Christmas but you
can pre-order it right now
we'll be spreading a good gospel of the
book for the next two months two and a
half months but again very excited it's
much more than basketball but I do get
into basketball and I do talk about
everything from being going to Michigan
being recruited by Bill Frieda at my
very first high school game I talked
about it Martin and Jalen talked about
growing up with parents one was a
teacher my father mechanic worked in the
auto industry over thirty years and so
this year we celebrated my parents 40th
wedding anniversary and just being there
with all the love the kids the family
old AAU coaches family it was just our
family celebrates all the time with
friends and that's what this book is
it's a book of it's a book definitely
won a celebration it's one of being
grateful in one of thanking the people
that were there for me and then just
looking back and saying well I had a
blast and hope for this inspire some
people that in the midst of their
journey that are going through some
tough things to kind of focus get right
into know better times ahead Chris
whoever here on the right choice and
chill when you say therapeutic what was
the most therapeutic for you here
that's a good question one of the things
that I learned while riding his book was
there's a verse in the Bible talks about
forgiving seven times seven times seven
so I always used to think that the
forgiveness meant rich is always going
to be late so if I have a thousand
parties forgive him for coming over late
or forgive them and it's not that it's
or or what I learned is it something
different and going through this book
you know a lot of the book concentrates
on when I was 12 13 years old when
you're first meeting people when you're
being recruited or groomed by certain
people and so when you go through
certain things and you've forgiven them
at that time let's say 30 years ago
well I'm remembering what happened going
over what happened and then you look at
it from a more mature standpoint say
wait a minute you really knew that I was
12 years old and things that you were
saying we're manipulative you really put
your claws in with words like family
loyalty those type of things these
people were trying to recruit you to
school trying to keep a job
to get you to say hi to another recruit
that would get them on the recruit you
know it's just so many so many things
that you really didn't know what the
situation was you just knew that
everything wasn't sincere and so I had
to forgive them again so even if you
forgive them when you get drafted
everything's great
I forgive you well not on 45-hour to say
wow that was really screwed up you did
that again and you know I forgive you
again and in the same tone ask for
forgiveness and in the same tone ask God
for forgiveness because at times you
didn't celebrate or enjoy things as you
should have because you were so focused
on what was going on at the time and so
for me it was just really um it just
really allowed me to look back at my
career to be thankful but also to take a
deep breath and to really appreciate all
the things that I've accomplished when
you're in sports you know the rule is if
you win on Wednesday and you can have
fun Wednesday night but Thursday morning
even if the game is until Saturday put
that out your hair so you're never in
the place of just constant being
grateful and that that's especially
since I retired the my frame that I've
been in and hopefully this book allows
me to show people how grateful I am but
also inspire them through that tough
well the Ed Martin you mentioned him
he's the individual with whom your
entanglements caused you to break with
Michigan and vice versa
yes how deep do you get into details
here I mean again I take full
responsibility for this book so I write
everything you know one of the tough
things rich was that say if I went on
the show and someone want to talk about
it right we would get four or five
minutes or whatever a good time for TV
but it's so much deeper and you have to
explain and go here and there that you
really could never have a conversation
that would end up being a soundbite that
I didn't think was fair to me or someone
didn't think was fair to them so I have
the full-on conversations from the day
that I met him to the day he passed away
to going to court to being accused of
things I don't want to give everything
away sure but to being accused of taking
money to go to Michigan I didn't take
money to go to Michigan never was the
case and will see through reporting in
the book how things go and how maybe
things could have been said if people
would have done a little more research
or just didn't jump on the bandwagon
those type of things and so
very proud of it it's definitely the
toughest thing that I've ever done and
I'm proud of it and I probably will
never read or write another word again
I'm Johnny it's it's an incredible
endeavor to do something like this and
when it comes out or you and Jaylyn
gonna be cool or what do we have on that
front you mentioned his name as well oh
I mean I'm you know I don't know you
know I don't know I'm I don't know I
don't really come from the school of
talking and bashing and putting out and
I don't know when he's where what gave
him the heart to do all that to become
that person I'm sure you know JaJuan is
at Michigan now which is wonderful so
I'm sure that will be a catalyst to
hopefully bring everybody back together
at the right time but as far as Michigan
goes right now I think it's time for
JaJuan establish his territories about
him you know so it's about him putting
down his rule setting a culture and none
of us should get in the way of that
whether through being nostalgic or or
trying to go back and get glory people
patting us on the back you know Chris
whoever here on the Rich Eisen show
you're a perfect guest to ask this
question to here in the state of
California the governor Gavin Newsom
just signed into law this was the a bill
that allows collegiate athletes to hire
an agent to make money off of their name
likeness and image off their name and
like what a novel idea and image wait
the NCAA doesn't own their name you know
what in the state of California it's a
totally different game and I'm wondering
what your thoughts are I already can
gather them right now so there was a
part in the book I talk about where
Mitch Albom came to the University of
Michigan it's a famous story even though
I took five million dollars to go to
Michigan or that's I guess that's what
some would say so I'm at the University
of Michigan it's my freshman year I'm
with a friend and it's after practice
and this is when you would give any
reported want to talk the time of day
and we were just at practice and walked
past the subway and very honestly I
don't have enough money to get a
sandwich it is what
as college that's the part of the good
things about college too because
hopefully it's the last time you have to
go through things like that you're a kid
it's fun and as soon as we walk past I
see the Michigan store you know back
then champion hoodies all this stuff was
which what she wanted and I remember and
I think he says this in his article but
I remember going to him is funny I'm
sitting there hungry you're a witness
and looked in that window and it was two
people with my Jersey I'll never forget
that uh
I'll never that's why during this whole
time 10 years people say oh you took
money or you did this I laugh cuz my
mind goes back to that story thinking I
should have taken money I should have
had a contract should have gotten paid
it was the highest enrollment at the
University of Michigan at the time it
was the fact that we knew we were
different we knew we were set in a stage
and that doesn't go with ego like oh
you're the best because there's
listening college kids you still got to
go on the next level it's also fact - it
is I mean when we put on black socks
what they were and and a great thing
about a rich I didn't we didn't know how
big we were so anybody says that in
hindsight they're lying we didn't know
we were big maybe some girls like this
and dudes like hey way to go but we
didn't know we were that big but seeing
them holding my two jerseys in there and
then realizing that you know my brothers
at home you know don't have Michigan
gear though those type of things hurt
and so when your athlete and you talk
about family this and that and you can't
give 10 shirts away that your family is
cheering for you back at home
and it's very interesting I'm very proud
of California but they've always been
ahead of the curve in some of those ways
it's going to be interesting to see what
happens but I think next what College
needs to do is what about the kids that
don't have the name but that gives you
gives you their body like I have friends
that are still hurt or they still deal
with problems from college and they're
45 years old and maybe they don't have
the health care to take care of
something from a torn ACL or something
like that you know what is the value of
education now versus well let me sign
this contract and see what I can get on
my own so you know whether it's a local
kid signing autographs at the local car
dealership for $200 for an hour or
whether it's him getting them
no video game I think that you know
there's a there's a lot of room left to
fill out and to make sure everybody's
protected well the Big Ten Commissioner
outgoing Jim Delaney is saying that once
you get past the cost of college in the
pocket of a student-athlete then there's
gonna be that's where things get thrown
off kilter once you get past the the
fact that you if the money is past the
amount of money that you're getting what
your scholarship is worth and that's an
issue and and are you here that's just
the latest of the sky is falling from
those in power do you think do you think
that the fact that an athlete would be
able to make that sort of cash would
throw off a balance of power
competitively in college sports because
they're amateur athletes right let me
ask you this this is where you get in
trouble let's just say live league
baseball right Little League baseball
huh have you seen the contract they
signed lifted with TV yes do the kids
get that or they amateurs but they're
amateurs but I have paid to play on TV
but they don't get money the the horse
left the barn a long time ago and so
when they put together this whole
Council last year of and of people that
never play sports that were never
recruited that never had a coach in
their home go yes son I'm gonna do that
I knew that it was Fugazi you know like
how can you do that without people that
were there without people that know the
games it's all um you just want to make
it look good but that but the American
fan is not stupid anymore and they had
never miss stupid but that the narrative
is changed everybody is saying listen
you know pay me fairly for what I
deserve or for what I work for and I'm
gonna have to have a whole nother
discussion about what's the value of
education what's the value of
opportunity what's the value of coming
out in debt and college loans you know
it's just a whole I hear this grace I
hear you I mean LeBron was asked just
this week why is it so personal to you
and he's like look if I go no Ohio State
and uh you know the Rena would have been
sold out my Jersey would have would have
been the number one seller I mean he
went on and on and on and he did not say
one thing that was untrue I mean it was
all and he would have gotten zero point
zero declares the fire because that's
what happened and and he's very honest
and we were blessed and lucky to be in
our situation so we was just that was
just by God's grace but sure you look at
you know LeBron you look at Zion last
year I mean those are two examples of
who we were at that time in real time
without social media and without social
media at that time to be that big you
were almost larger than the largest on
social media because you're rumors you
know had that much more influence in
power LeBron is a hundred percent right
I mean we have to put it back into the
hands of the individuals who have their
last names on the jersey and simply you
know so I definitely agree with LeBron
but I do think that there is an answer I
do think there is a way but it has to be
an honest conversation and I think that
those in power in the NCAA that are
making money are so scared of the honest
conversation because they don't know
what they're gonna lose by having an
honest conversation but nothing will
happen no narrative will change nothing
will happen until we have those
conversations Chris Webber loved our
conversations all the time like God's
grace you can pre-order it right now
we're all books are sold
oh yes and then December 18th yes week
before Christmas yes a nice photograph
right there younger picture I didn't
have to put in these I was gonna you
know any black over the grave that
looked like somebody before they had
twins who were now - yeah somebody who
got a night's sleep you start the book
off with foam trust in the trust in the
reader because that the biggest struggle
in my life was having children it wasn't
I talk about the time now to talk about
the the highest of the highs and the
devastating lows that I've had in my
life before I was fifteen four of my
friends were murdered that could play
basketball but why weren't they here now
you know it was a lot of like survivor's
remorse and thinking of those things but
really when it got the God's grace I was
in the hospital room and I saw my baby
and I was told I never there they go I
was told I got gray hair my wife and I
was told for eight years that we never
have them and so for people out there
that are told you know things can't
happen for those out there to have
expectations for those that hit you know
dry spots in their life God is good and
and and what I would say to those that
say well Chris um it's not about a
religious experience I would say that
for me it is and i would say for others
the grace of God means look who's around
look at the parents that around you look
at your coaches look at your teachers
who's cultivating those are your angels
you don't have to put it in a religious
context but we do not make ourselves we
do not get here this successful you're
good but yeah you're really good at what
you do but you didn't do this by
yourself you got all these great people
in here you had your parents you went to
Michigan you worked your butt off what
about the professor that inspires you
know if I got deep into your story to be
able to say that not just hope people
take a little bit of time and and hug
that village you know thank those people
around them to help them get to this
point let's bring out what to call you a
friend too sir thank my wife loves as
you know I like you are 40 I know that I
understand I get thrown onto this see
wet bus every single time your name gets
matching good to secrecy - that's real
Chris Webber on Twitter Instagram as
well and go get by God's grace a book
that I can't wait to read myself sir
thank you that's Chris Webber right
here's four more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel - 39 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app